and we have this uh Ann Coulter substack
unsafe you have this this is really
interesting letter from the New York
Times executive editor Joe Khan to staff
writing about what happened with the the
trans uh rights activists and leftist
activists coming after them but uh do
you want to give us the gist of it and
it was leaked Jimmy I was the first one
to send it out
um
I mean I know this from other reporters
at the New York Times that they they do
still have some serious journalists who
know how to do journalism they're very
smart they're very skilled but then I
don't know a few years ago they brought
in all the worksters and it's just like
this cloud of locusts who go around
attacking people who are doing the
actual job of putting a newspaper out
and the the executive editor is this guy
Joe Khan
um I looked him up on Wikipedia very
impressive person he's old style New
York Times which I disagreed with it was
liberal but it was written well and they
didn't lie
um the crazy thing this letter he's
sending it around because actual I guess
reporters and editors and probably HR
Representatives at the New York Times
have signed on to this and letter
representing the trans people attacking
the New York Times for its coverage of
trans issues and it's a very gentle
letter but it is him standing up to the
walksters saying you can't be an
activist and attacking people at the
organization you work for and that's the
gist of the letter which shows that
there are still some sane people at the
New York Times and who knows and as soon
as they retire yeah yeah the woke people
take over and then the New York Times I
wouldn't be surprised if they changed
their name to like you know uh down with
whiteness times right.org or something
the only reason I think they wouldn't is
because it's such an institution and
they get to say we are the oldest
newspaper and therefore we are the
authority newspaper of record yeah we're
right yeah
one of my commenters on on the sub stack
said if you didn't do this for a living
would you subscribe to the New York
Times
[Music]
and I thought about it no no I'd read
The Daily Mail every day they have 10
million members paying what like 10
bucks a month
some ridiculous I mean in some ways it
is the leading newspaper in America
right people think of it first when they
think it's just famous yeah I mean they
people are it's it would be better to
subscribe to your local newspaper and
get actual news from people who know
what's going on in your life if you want
to feel like you are I mean some stuff
is going to be AP but local crime for
example that's going to be yeah of
course things or Daily Mail right things
that will impact your life you need
someone who's actually reporting on them
and I think people instead see it as
like oh well I'm I'm an informed
intellectual I I list I read the New
York Times I mean I know some people who
very well intentions will tell me oh I
listen to the New York Times Daily
podcast and that's where I get a lot of
my news and they're they're doing an
honest effort to be informed right but
it's hard to then look at them be like
but that's not the one put your
tomtemcast.com I do all the time I know
well they do still have some good
reporters but you really have to
search for and it isn't that strange
that you have to search for the good
reporter and I think leaders are often
you know sucking some of the information
out for example the race of any black
criminal oh in Sweden it's crazy I
remember uh when I was covering the news
covering the big story in Sweden when
Trump came out and said last night in
Sweden I went there they actually not
only would they blur the the skin of the
criminal they would alter the pixel
color to make it seem like it was a
white person who got blurred
oh that's crazy huh
it's like dude come on that's that's
more racist in my opinion wow yeah going
it's it's all just still racism the idea
that you can't like the they were
basically saying the population could
not handle learning that not white
people would commit crimes yeah like any
person can commit a crime dude come on
that's what they do that's what they do
and that's putting a lot of girls at
risk oh yeah yeah yeah did you go like
fully independent now are you you're
totally independent at the moment well I
always have been oh so you just like
never worked I mean since I left I sent
a Judiciary Committee basically are you
going to write another book
because you know I'd love to ask you
guys for one thing I've written 13 books
all New York Times bestsellers they're
excellent books they yes thanks to
Vanessa my publicist is sitting here
um
I think I for one thing I think I've
said it all I mean mugged is about crime
it's the I've said it all immigration
Trump we in Trump We Trust I'm telling
you that is a great book even though he
turned out to be a grifter and a liar
um what he was what he was saying and
doing was great
um demonic on the French Revolution on
Mob Behavior about antifa I don't think
there's any better explanation of that
treason the history of of a lot of our
Wars
um if you wanted to know about
impeachment I don't think there's you
wouldn't write about DeSantis you
wouldn't write about well I need a point
I don't write oh and he was born in
there's got to be an over a point that I
don't think people know and I I think
every one of these books guilty about
the victimology culture and everybody
wanting to be a victim he was offended
first wins
um there's so much great stuff in that
books that anything that is a large
topic I've already written about it
which is more than I thought I was going
to write I thought I was done after my
third book and after every book I said
well that's it I got nothing else you
thought you were done after your third
book and then 10 books always said to me
you say that after every book have
Publishers giving you a hard time with
uh the topics that you choose or do you
find that you get free reign because you
are such an established you know
intellectual well my second book that
um
your older listeners may have heard me
say this
um my the the the story in book
publishing is you don't make money on
your first bestseller you make it on the
advance to your next book well my first
book out of the gate High crimes and
misdemeanors it was a New Year's Times
bestseller and for quite a while
um
and I couldn't get a second book
published
not a publisher I wrote the book my
editor died he was magnificent I
dedicated the book to him
um and the publisher Harper Collins
Rupert Murdoch Brook Collins took the
opportunity to cancel the book and I had
you know the star agent Joni Evans she
was the Hotshot book agent she's
shopping it around to all of her Pals on
Publishers Row in New York City and they
absolutely would not publish a book by
me and she'd send me their emails back
back to me saying things like
Ouija my second book was slander about
liberal laws about the American right a
lot about the media man that's a good
book
um and they'd write to her we do not
think this would move the public
dialogue forward what and I'd emailed
Joni back saying you know that's so
weird because I thought Publishers made
money on the basis of how many books
sold not Matt how many inches they moved
the public dialogue for and anyway it
was the number one book All Summer One
Crown publishing finally published it
and I taunted Publishers row all year
there's always going to be something to
write about because now with like defund
the police with crime running rampant
the next all in mugged well but I just
mean like the next thing's gonna come
soon right the left will come out with
some some new insane policy idea and
then yeah I'd be like oh heavens me time
to write a book have you or would you
update audios America because
immigration is not getting better in
fact
I think every word is perfect but you
wouldn't I'm sorry I'm sounding like Ian
now
as always you wouldn't update it with a
new chapter after after uh Biden term
Biden let in 5 million illegals I think
the book is perfect it's like going back
and trying actually the Mona Lisa isn't
that great
touching up it's wonderful and it's
Simplicity
well I don't know Trump talks you know
in its crude fashion it's not crude it's
that
um
unlike apparently everyone as we found
out today who works for Fox I say what I
think is true I mean this is my intro
letter to sub stack I didn't mention any
particular conservative network but it's
all about being on TV and having the job
and okay you may not like what I'm
saying and maybe sometimes I'm wrong
um but you can always be sure that I am
saying what I believe to be true we now
have all of the fox hosts saying they
knew Trump's election claims were BS
they knew it was crazy they thought
Giuliani was out of his mind and Cindy
Powell was out of her mind and they're
going on TV and presenting it to the
viewers so I blame Fox News as much as
Trump for what's happened to the
Republican party and why who was it that
was saying did you say you have
you have friends who it was January 6th
they say they'll never vote Republican
again no it wasn't me oh maybe it was
downstairs maybe downstairs because of
the way it was handled people say
they'll never vote Republican it was so
out no that it was outrageous that it
even happened they are blaming
Republicans for that well why did it
happen why is it still happening because
and I look some of these people are my
friends in conservative talk radio and
TV and I yell at them all the time they
say oh when we have you on you know
ratings go down everybody's mad
everybody writes in they're saying
they're oh don't believe that I
fundamentally do not believe that when
you go on their ratings go down well not
ratings go down but they get a lot of
hate mail well sorry no it is the most
listened to of the show is MSNBC
inviting you want to talk bad about
Trump
no no you have to say the same but
well I think what happened the reason
they feel like they're getting more
viewers and they're getting less hate
mail is
after the 2020 election I I have TV on
in every room of my house to MSNBC so
that I can just walk through the room
and hit the mute button and never miss
anything they say even I couldn't listen
to it after for a it's very repetitive
but B once Biden wins Democrats have the
house Democrats have the Senate it's
like do I want to see you know Moment by
moment report on a slow-motion plane
crash there's nothing we can do we're
being gonna be strangled to death until
it gets fun until jungen ran until the
seances is running then it'll be fun
again so I think normal people and I'm
not even normal and I couldn't watch
political news I was just watching
Forensic Files so the only people I
think still tuning into cable news
are the are the Trump Fanatics thanks
for watching this clip from the timcast
IRL podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time